it's time for drew's news your daily
wiggle of those good news ears
not like a sign like oh it's like a like
a carol brunette thing right and like
baseball there's lots of oh yeah you
know i don't really know that much about
basically
but with me at the death is a man who
does know about football russell that's
right that's right go long hi everybody
hi
hi gorge um hi hey
um i see we're in our mav tones today
yeah i was inspired i thought i got
something that matches that i love it
well i'm excited because it is
apparently the 20th anniversary of the
film a walk to remember what oh my gosh
of course with mandy moore nicholas
sparks
shane west every oh well there you go i
remember this movie i'm still i'm still
recovering from this movie it was so sad
well people reports that mandy moore
wouldn't mind seeing a remake and she
even said she really wishes to see
olivia rodrigo i love her
because
she's a great actress she has beautiful
pipes i love that that's so sweet and
like endearing um yeah because if i had
a classic movie i i'd be and they wanted
to remake it i'd be like no i already
did it it was perfect thank you you
don't need to do that
speaking of winning things you guys are
ready for the winter olympics they're
here
and you know the extra hurdle
which is a olympic pun another hurdle uh
is trying to keep all the athletes
covered safe this time of year well to
do it beijing is firing up robots yeah
food and wine reports people dining in
the olympic cafeteria will have their
meal dropped from the ceiling by a big
robot arm look at this
yeah burgers will be cooked up by a
robot chef drinks will be served by a
robo bartender i want i want a robo
bartender hello
you know i was at a hotel in sonoma
recently and i was in the lobby and this
i swear to you a robot went by me with
like lights meet me like buy me like
this and i said what this is not a joke
i said what is this robot they said we
call her rosie and you can order things
to your room so you know i was like
dial in rosie and i ordered a bottle of
wine and next thing i know my doorbell
ding-dong and i open it and there's this
robot and she goes
this thing opens and there's a bottle of
wine right there i wanted to propose to
rosie this was
that's amazing right well also kind of i
expected more rosy and less the claw
well this is like it's the clock i don't
call that a robot it's not a robot have
you ever been able to grab anything with
that claw you know who can who olive
your daughter she can her nickname is
bear and if i ever want to encourage her
i go get that salmon bear get that
salmon
and she
she gets that salmon she is a master at
the clash she gets everything she goes
after oh wow and she's the only one i
know because i think that thing is just
you know a money sucker yeah no that's
terrible um it's a claw to your wallet
and your dignity
[Music]